[Music]
hello and welcome we are here to look at
how the pros prepare and in fact what
we're going to look at this night is how
to prepare like a
goat and um the first game actually is
sort of an Easter egg because you may
think
you're looking at one goat and in fact
there is two but this time the one on
the receiving end is a goat
himself Gary Kasparov needs no
introduction nor does vishy but I will
elaborate that in a moment so whenever
you're preparing for a game it really
boils down of understanding of what
position you're trying to have or you're
trying to accomplish so let's dig in so
E4 C6 D4 D5 this is the caroan very
popular some decade ago and it is still
fairly popular although E5 so E4 E5 and
E4 C5 is surpassing it in
popularity however it is still very
popular D4 Knight D2 Bishop F5 the main
main line even though karpov against
Kasparov himself did go Knight D7 with
some success including with um including
his famous win against gakamsky Bishop
F5 Bishop G6 H4 Knight F3 H5 Bishop D3
now notice that white is trying to win
as much time as
possible and he's also trying to fix
Black's structure on the king side then
that actually will become quite
important
towards the Middle Gate Bishop F4 E6
Bishop E7 now Bishop E7 signals that
black actually consider is going short
when before Queen A5 Check used to be
the big big line so instead of E6 Queen
A5 here Queen C7 and castles long
castles and this used to be the big main
line but since then they switched over
to E6 Bishop E7 with the intention to
Castle so whenever you prepare for a
position you kind of have to decide what
you're aiming for black in fact decides
to choose a structure that is rather
sound yet fairly passive cuz white is
the only one with quite a lot of space
although there will be a controversial
question whether the H Pawn is a
strength or weakness so that's sort of
another reason why carom players like
playing their variation because the H5
Pawn actually can become a
Target so King B1 castles Knight E4
preparing the idea of G4 which in fact
was played in a game between Judit pogar
and vishy himself Knight takes C4 this
is the most solid Queen takes Knight F6
Queen E2 Queen to
D5 Knight
E5 Queen E4 and a quick question is what
would you do would you trade would you
try to avoid the trade of
Queens is actually a very important
question and it's something that
definitely both Gary and the other
players I'm going to talk about looked
at because you have to decide before you
actually go there and play your game
what will be your game plan are you
going for an allout attack or are you
content with a position with a slight
bit of a
pull should we
take should we
block we could also consider Queen D2
however I've haven't really seen that
move being
played so we've got plenty of people
trying to
avoid would you avoid or would you trade
the Queens TR trade okay uh why would
you trade by the way because I'm not a
very strong player SO trading Queens
against a great player is always
desirable okay that's not a good reason
no that's a good reason you have your
own reasons and that's completely valid
for you that's great trading because
you're trading against a very good
player now that is correct and Gary
actually goes into the end
now Bishop
E3 does feel very combative but it turns
out that Knight D5 and black gets very
comfortable counterplay against the
bishop and the spin is actually kind of
annoying Queen takes E4 so what Gary
decided and decided early before he even
entered this game versus vishy that this
ending is favorable for him
it's a very nice position Knight takes
C4 Rook E1 you can't quite take this
it's poisoned because there's Rook D2
and I'm going to pick up that Knight
Knight cannot really run
away Knight
F6 so it's one thing to consider a
position
advantageous but there are some
strategic elements that makes this
position quite Fair aable for
white what could be a reason white can
claim some
advantage in fact it is deeply connected
to that H
PA as black is threatening our Pawn on
H5 the extra space is nice very good how
however if you look at the position
white has an extra Pawn here on the
Queen's side black has these guys while
black has a majority on the king side
however there's a huge difference
between the two Pawn structures that
makes this so much more favorable than a
usual
position so if you imagine how white is
going to mobilize his pawns it's fairly
straightforward you are going to start
rolling your pawns can you say the same
thing about Black's
position can black freely roll his
pawns Black's majority isn't mobile
right now that's correct
and also notice because Gary has a Pawn
on
H5 all these pawn moves that would try
to uh
facilitate the majority the Palm
majority on the king's side doesn't work
because white would just capture and
suddenly there wouldn't be a strength
but a liability in the
position so therefore Gary makes sure
that these pawns are over defended and
basically clamping
down on Black's King side so this is one
of the reasons why deep opening
preparation is key at the highest
level they look for a position where the
prospects we will favor them in the long
run and in this case black really
doesn't have a lot of Hope of
counterplay the counter play will always
be passive and will always be most of
trying to make or holding the position
for a
draw Rook d8 Bishop E3 Bishop D6 F3
notice that Gary is very quick to get
rid of all of his weaknesses so he can
play for two
results does this count as a minor
minority attack well in a minority
attack you attack the majority of Pawns
in this case you're more like clamping
down on black structure so you're just
making sure it doesn't run away but
that's actually a great point there is
the famous game between kchoi versus
karpov where he does the exact same
thing but on the other side of the board
he's actually just clamping that down
but on the Queen's
side okay so you look at this position
we also have to identify whether trades
will favor us or will it favor
Black
and remember white has the space
Advantage so that should be sort of a
giveaway well in reality we really
shouldn't trade that much Rook C8 C4
however for now they can't quite take on
E E5 because the a pawn is
hanging standard guidance not to trade
when you have more space that is correct
A5
A4 keeping black from advancing too much
and also restricting
counterplay so you'll see in other games
how they treat the position but it is
quite exemplary how Kasparov treats this
position
he doesn't let vishy cross over to the
other side why already has reached
Black's Camp so not only does he have
the center
control but he also has a Pawn on H5
already infiltrating black next position
that is so Knight D7 Bishop
D2 going after another weakness Bishop
C7 Bishop C3 Knight takes D takes
C5 okay so white of course still managed
uh to have an advantage however because
vishi is defending skillfully there is a
new found
danger what's that new found danger we
got to look out
for and in fact something that calls him
never really liked in fact was something
that he even denied
exist
fortresses
so Vish she even though is in a verse
position but if there is no breakthrough
a better position is not even
Venable so white will have to tread
carefully so as V she can block off all
the play in the position but for now
Kasparov brings his King Rook takes King
takes D1 Rook d8 King E2 Rook
D7 but look out for this if we start
trading or if we keep trading we won't
have enough pieces left to break
through so our duty in this position
will be to find a way to create a Target
in Black's camp that we can
attack well of course this is a space
related
position
however in this case there are some ways
you can strengthen the position and
Kasparov obviously
did
so for now we can't really do too
much on the queen side because of this
PO itial B7 to B6 pawn
move
so sometimes the answer to your question
where does my Rook belong is that there
is no clear answer for now it really
doesn't belong
anywhere so if it's not a rook move and
not and neither a bishop move because
the bishop is stuck defending the Eon
however it is still in the best position
it could be that leaves us with palm
moves F4 very good well done chat F4
threatening F5 but also threatening G5
let's say black would ignore this white
could consider Pawn to G5 as well
because if you manage to trade then you
get a majority and white has potential
ideas of opening up the G file and
potentially the F and H for the rook and
once The Rook infiltrates there are very
real chances of winning the game not to
mention that white can also create a
passer with
H6 but apart from that there's also the
idea of F5 of course vishy does not let
Gary go play
G5 Bishop
G5 trying to go for a counter play but
as the bishop
leaves it actually leaves an important
defensive idea
open so this bishop no
longer is defending the B6
square and that gives
Kasparov the legend a new fancy
idea and that's actually one of the
reasons you shouldn't decide to early
where your pieces should go because that
could be a waste of time that's why F4
F5 was so much
stronger bring the Rook exactly first
went F6 B6 but now he goes Rook A1 Rook
A3 Rook B3 so it was actually essential
to get this pawn move over here cutting
off this bishop so it can't go back and
defend and after B6 go Rook A1 Rook A3
Rook B3 pressing that B6 Pawn so notice
how efficient kaspar can be with his
pieces first he goes with the pawn storm
and once vishy reacts that actually
gives him an easier time deciding where
his Rook will belong and now it was much
more clearcut that his Rook actually
should go to A3 B3 and to attack and put
the blacks Queen side under
siege Rook d8 Rook A3 G G takes Rook B3
now if you look at this in general pawns
that are farther away so past pawns
potential past pawns are much more
valuable than Pawns in the middle
because they're unlikely to become
Queens that's just a simple reason so
Bishop
F4 Rook takes B6
Bishop takes E5 and this is a critical
moment where if I am correct yes this is
the critical
moment where actually Gary makes a
slight
inaccuracy Rook B8 does not really work
because of tactical ideas of Bishop
takes
A5
Bishop takes A5 and they're just too
many pass pawns for
white here Gary goes for the trade on E5
which is a little bit
Hasty but Rook C6 would have been much
much stronger as he's going to pick up
those pawns and doesn't let vishy get
immediate
counterplay and his position is much
much better in that
case so takes Rook B5 Rook D4 and
suddenly vishy is still fighting Rook
takes takes B3 never forget anytime you
play an ending make sure you over defend
your
pawns and it is still clear that white
is the one pushing because his pawns are
just more more dangerous because these
pawns are going to be stopped by the
King on E2 Rook G3 takes Rook takes
A5
F5 check King
G7 okay question is which
Pawn should white start
pushing which Pawn will become
stronger remember we reached the End
Game
Zone and in the end Game Zone there are
New pieces that gain and have new found
powers you can push the H Pawn that's my
feeling
too but that's just a
hunch
he goes for the sea pawn and you might
be thinking huh why not the a pawn the
thing is if you push the a pawn black is
going to catch the other pawn and just
stop this other Pawn from
behind then in fact C5 is better because
the king is
closer cuz if this King king would ever
catch up to the C Pawn it's game
over because the king actually be
nursing and supporting the C Pawn with
the a pawn you can't do the same thing
it's just far away from the white
king So C5
played Rook
C8 C6 Rook E8 you don't actually have
time to defend this because C7 and
promotes
so I have to go here Rook takes
E6 F4 check King D3
now black is actually very close to
equality however with time trouble
looming large it's quite an ous
defense now here Black Goes Rook C5 King
D4
King E4 check Rook
C3 and because of time
trouble white
actually moves the king but wi has a
brilliant way to win
already can we spot the winning idea for
white
well King E5 white is still going to
have to face palm
pushes King E4 all these King moves
that's very very similar to what Gary
did but that's not the direction we're
going
for F6
F3 so you have to understand what is the
biggest danger you're facing in this
position as white it's the
FB and what actually is hard to notice
is that the Rook this
time is even
stronger from
G2 F3 Rook
F2 King h8 King D6 King
G7 King D7
check C7 well that's not exactly so King
G7 turns out that Rook F1 is an incred
incredibly incredibly strong
move because at the end of the day if
the black king tries to come
forward then you push the pawn check and
you just walk away from this pawn and
there is this beautiful tactical shot
now Rook F1 is an incredibly difficult
move to
play but it turns out that black really
doesn't have anything else to do I can't
really make any other progress apart
from going to F6 but in that case as I
showed this is the beautiful idea and
the other thing is if black does nothing
does something
meaningless at the end of the
day you say you keep on
checking white is going to have a fairly
nice little idea that wins on the spot
so let's show our endgame
skills let's see how white can just win
the
position and that's actually why the
Rook is preferred to be in front of the
Pawn in this
case and not behind it because it would
lose a lot of
tempo and also this is the key idea that
otherwise wouldn't necessarily
work yep it is indeed the Lucina Rook B1
over defending the bou notice if you do
this I still check you
forever now of course the problem is the
King was there but let let's say the
king moves to G7 instead here I would
just keep checking you forever whenever
you move away I attack the pawn so it is
of upmost importance you put the Rook on
B1 and even if you go F2 I just go King
B8 and Rook B3 I just capture and
promote so you have no ways of saving
this
position this Pawn is neutralized and so
is the idea of checking from behind
and that is actually an important lesson
from this end game to learn you may want
to defend frontally especially when your
Rook can help out with the
defense now the game ended in a more
tragic
way so he went King
D4 here King E4 check King h8 played
this move which was really bad and it's
already losing takes Rook D6 King G4
check C7 and resigns the king is cut
this is also an underrated way of
cutting the
king and not only is that cut the AG
Pawn is going to run down the board and
you can't stop both of
them so you could take away from this
game well a you want to know where your
Rook belongs it's always very tricky in
these end in these end games but first
and foremost choosing the right opening
is key when you're playing Elite
level so let's take a look at another
game featuring the very same opening so
this is Vladimir Kik versus
yv
that's fast
forward here Bishop B7 takes Queen D3
Queen D5 there is a little bit of a
difference but it is practically
negligible it was this one in the
previous
one and also the queen was on
E2 but this
time white actually doesn't go Rook E1
also it doesn't work as well because the
pawn has been committed to C4 so there
are some little details like here it
takes actually still works because it's
defended but in this game Kik already
doesn't go Rook E1 but goes Bishop E3
immediately Knight
D6 okay so we reach this end game very
same end
game but different move
moves so it is in some sense
unique how should white
continue yes that is
true Rook E1 actually doesn't work work
because of Knight F2 Knight G4 good
point so this is what we call an in
betweener it's not really an ending but
it's still sort of a middle game right
so there are some dangers still lurking
in this
position
now if we would
push the B2 Pawn would that
be too big of a
weakness or
not
that's a simple question either we're
afraid or we're not
afraid chat are you
afraid or you're not afraid of no
ghosts I'm not afraid I push it push it
okay I believe B3 it was indeed
played so in this position with the
Queen's already off the
board all these squares well if they can
exploit it immediately then we'd care
about it but of course it's more of an
ending this looks more of like the
ending type of
position and it doesn't really strike
much fear in White's
heart 95 is a little bit risky because
you're
underestimating potential ideas of
trying to capture the E5 Knight so you
always have to be careful Black's
position even though passive it can
become quite
venomous if you don't tread
carefully and that's actually one of the
reasons it is so
popular so B3 and here B have actually
plays the stock idea and the idea that
is actually quite nice in these
positions and what black should be
aiming
for black definitely has to go for some
level of counterplay or else he's going
to end up in the previous game as the
previous game shows which was a featured
between Kasparov and
Anand so this is an end
yet Bishop F6 and B5 is a typical idea
in the
Caro now white does not really want to
commit to
C5 not just yet at least because it
would definitely weaken that square and
black may actually take advantage of
that and slowly but surely it'd be black
who would be preferred
so night D2 keeping the
tension and here but plays King D7 but
I'm not a huge fan I definitely think
the king should still castle and even
though the position is technically an
ending the king will actually find
itself in
crossfire King D7 well in general black
doesn't have like an easy way or any
concrete way of taking advantage of this
structure and also note that crime neck
made sure that no and none of these
jumps actually
work so King D7 and that is definitely a
dubious
idea King
C2 so kic is ready to over defend those
pawns so in this sense this whole
opening is somewhat double-edged even
though white has the extra space white
does have to tend for the D4 pawn and
then later the C4 Pawn because they will
be heavily attacked and bombarded by
black
pces Bishop d8 not a lucky move and in
fact something we should try and
punish yeah Bishop d8 is actually not
that great
now it is not a bad idea to recall how
people played in previous games however
every position is unique in itself so
trying to use the same idea all the time
will not provide you the desired
results
so Black's move of Bishop d8 is somewhat
suspicious because it loses bit of
control which squares got a bit loose
because of that
move no the bishop never really
controlled the D5
Square the E5
Square Knight F3 and that's actually an
important thing to notice that whenever
your opponent makes a move that is
slightly passive and moves away from the
center you should always look around if
you can take advantage of that in fact
karnick spots a tactical idea that you
can't quite take here because Knight E5
check and I can capture it back with a
Tempo so Bishop F6 Knight D5 check you
can still take it
because of the E and the immediate pin
king C7
C5 now he goes for
C5 Bishop takes C5 D takes Knight
C8 so far so good but I have probably
hopes to get the Knight to
D5 however there's some weaknesses in
Black's position
that Kik can go after and he
did Rook
H3 so that's one of those
things you're going for the template
ideas chess is more than just the
templates that's actually the greatest
misunderstanding in
chess everyone who never played a chess
game thinks it's about templates
I go F4 F5 this is what I saw this is
what I need to do I win I'm a genius
look at me that's not what chess is
about Chess is about subtlety chess is
about understanding the little
differences all those little things that
seemingly don't
matter that little difference that kic
didn't actually go after four but went
for Rook
H3 why did he go Rook
H3
well he's putting immediate pressure on
the F7
Pawn indeed a very clippable
moment of kck's
play ight E7 Rook F3
here Rook
D6 Just Landing the eagle in Black's
position it's quite painful it is a
little bit reminiscent of Rook A3 Rook
B3 exactly so there are synchronicities
in these
position
A5
G5 doing the same idea that kaspar was
hoping to get but this time karnick
actually gets there ticks Bishop ticks
Knight F5
should we or should we not give up our
Rook on
D6 should we I think we should okay why
why should we sacrifice The Exchange I
want to sacrifice The Exchange because
there will be a really good
okay that's a good point however let me
play devil's advocate here if you don't
mind do you have a good
position as
whitee
mid well can black do
anything so if I don't do nothing with
white I just move my Rook
away like can't really do too much
would that change your
mind not really because you can't
actually put your rook in front of mine
because I own the d8 square and if I
start doubling up on the defile I may be
able to get in and it's almost
Checkmate
so whenever you're trying to make a
decision of course you consider the
sacrifice but you got to keep in mind do
I have a
position that has an plus has an
advantage if you already do you don't
need to
sacrifice so Rook D1 A4 B4 again no
counterplay for BV he's avoiding all of
that Shenanigans crnas King C8 Rook D3
Rook A7 Rook d8 take take King B7 and
you can already sense
something's absolutely off in Black's
position all right so we got a great
position here as white what should we
do remember all your endgame
studies and that should be good enough
for you to
find White's
plan I can see
everyone is looking forward for some
fireworks however a rook is still a
rook it's worth a
lot and again that's sort of a
distraction this is an end game
right you got to
bring the king you got to bring the king
king C3 King D3 King E4 bring in the
king so first and foremost never
forget number one rule the king needs to
participate
in the end
game this is the moment
though where white can play a dazzling
little
move actually Waits For
It Rook
d8 King F4 check check here King C and
now he
plays that beautiful
idea that makes this a
brilliancy black really couldn't do
anything in between he was just stalling
and waiting
around
Bishop F6 very
good quite a beautiful move the point
is you can't quite capture because I
capture back and White's Simple Plan is
going to go King G5 H6
H7 if you ever sacrifice the Knight it's
game over
my king is just going to go to G7 and
you're
lost so Rook C8 although black can still
try so that's take how that works takes
takes King G5 King D7
here well yeah so Knight
D4
H6 Knight F3 King H5 Knight
E5 so we do need to calculate a little
bit even though we should exude some
confidence that we are actually
winning but okay that actually gives
credit to kik's
calculation you got to be accurate but
you are
winning
F4 I manage to come back home and also I
might be able to capture that
pawn so you may have to be
quick with your Pawn H7 of course Knight
G6 King H6 mhm King D7
and now G yes
E5 you got better much simpler you are
on the right track but you don't even
have to take on up St oh so it's a
mhm
take
G mhm and it's
gone Swan you can't make a single move
black runs out of moves of course if you
go A3 F3 that is the same thing so
notice that white
purposefully never push this Pawn
because in endings if you have that
extra tempo that can be a game Cher
remember that because that's key pal
pushes be fairly conservative with
that and otherwise the position just
collapses takes King G5 and BV resigns
because white is just going to pick up
the G and the E pawns and there's just
no hope for a success uccessful
defense so a magnificent game by
kramnick where he completely
dominated Black's position and Black's
play now surprise
surprise I didn't talk much about vishy
but this is the moment to talk about
vishy right now this she
undoubtedly one of the best players of
of all time I would put him in top three
now they used to call him the lightning
kid but I really think we should just
call him the grandfather of Indian chess
because that's who he is he was the one
who put India on the map and in fact is
one of the very few players who won all
forms of World Championships
very few other players even managed to
get there also notice that vishy was a
bit like Bobby fiser in the
sense that he faced a slew of EX Soviet
players and
succeeded with getting the chess crown
and all kinds of versions knockout not
knockout round robin and the classical
world championship match and matches so
even though vishy is not extolled enough
let's give vishy his due and let's see
how he actually learns from a previous
loss and takes up ponomarov with the
same defense he faced and he was facing
Gary Kasparov displaying the exact same
weapon he had to face before
Bishop F4 Knight E4
takes C4 takes Bishop E3
castles so we already understood from
the previous games what why should be
aiming
for so as we already kind of built a
little bit of a game collection of
what's Happening Here finding the moves
for white shouldn't be that hard so
let's try to predict or guess what vishy
did in this
position 95 95 and what will be your
plan mhm okay so 95 is a beautiful move
is there any weaknesses in White's
position that needs extra
Defenders
well yeah but also remember you've got a
pawn that wandered off a little bit so
right now of course you have a rook
defending it but in the long run you'll
have to make sure it has Pawn support
otherwise those pawns can become
isolated from the white
Camp yeah so Knight E5 indeed exactly
what he played F3 Knight G3 so he's sort
of sabotaging the play Rook H3 obviously
you don't want to drop this Pawn so
remember this is an ending you can't
just give up pawns willy-nilly unless
you have immediate counter
play like here black could take so Vue
of course defends
it Bishop
F2 Rook d8 G4 so G4 actually has this
dual purpose of not just chasing the
Knight away but over defending these
pawns and creating this beautiful Pawn
chain which is typical to the
caroon Knight
E7 Knight D3 again a very strong move
and you can see how chess is evolving in
previous games black was allowed to
capture on E5 but vishy doesn't want to
allow it this time
B5 we of course go B3 Bishop C7 Rook
hh1 now this is that little move that
most of the time not many talk about but
it's a sign of a really really strong
player a true
goat why because you're making sure
that you don't have any bad pieces this
Rook on H3 seems okay right now but it's
sort of pointless and it'd be much more
useful protecting the D1 rook and also
it may join the battle via Rook H E1 so
Rook H H1 is a very strong move Bishop
B6 Knight C5 and Knight C5 5 looks
surprising
however vishy understands the position
better and again that goes back to the
deep understanding and the Deep
preparation of these players this she is
not afraid of the doubled pawns on the C
file after the trade on C4 and C5
because he
notices a big difference what's the
biggest difference
between wh's position and Black's
position and I really want to focus
mostly on the light
pieces the bishop on F2 is just stronger
than the Knight on E7 the Knight on E7
is actually hindered by his pawns on C6
and again node the pawns on H5 and
G4 this just no way for that Knight to
come about and get to a better spot so
yes these pawns look loose but there's
no way for ponomarov to go after them
and also that Knight on E7 is sort of
stuck now in the long
run what do you think white could
do
to actually build a much bigger
Advantage What would be a long-term
plan cuz it's one thing that the Knight
on E7 is bad but that in itself won't
mean you to
game note that there are some Targets in
Black's position the A7 Pawn C6 Pawn but
for
now you know there's no way to get to
them
you can't quite move your king and here
you got to be careful with King moves
because Rooks are still on the board
that's actually an exception always be
careful when the Rooks are still
around Rook takes
D okay and if I capture back after Rook
takes d8 I
thought okay and you want to
infiltrate okay you could also so
consider in the long run to get your
Bishop along this
diagonal so always notice if your Bishop
can participate or deny a square for
your opponent because if you manage to
deny the d8 square you can freely enter
via D7 and then that Rook is going to
spell disaster all along the seventh
file I mean seventh rank so C5 Rook D6
also annoying because you can't move
here you drop the pawn you can't take
because I'm going to create a connected
pass Pawn not to mention that it's also
winning on the
spot so Rook B8 Rook D1 double up if you
can double up you always should in
endings Rook d8 takes takes King H7 Rook
f8
F6 so vishy actually manages to
infiltrate not the seventh because
ponomar of defended that but the eighth
but it's already kind of uncomfortable
there's no counterplay the whole concept
of White's opening that white actually
has a quasi extra Pawn on the other side
as black is completely paralyzed on the
king's side however that's one one thing
you still have to win the
game and you have to create a strong
strong passer for
white but in viy you should
trust and I hope you'll find This
brilliant brilliant
idea from a
not
so right now we don't have a way to
infiltrate and that Rook is annoyingly
placed from a white perspective how can
we try to lure it away or chase it away
rather
well if you move your Bishop around that
doesn't really lure The Rook away at all
exactly so white gets
ready and starts rolling the a pawn
up and that will give vishan access to
the B7
Square A4 Pawn is heading to A6 G6 A5
now of course you never can go there
there cuz I just pick up the pawn and
I'm
winning takes takes Rook B8
A6 Bishop A5 now this wouldn't still win
yet because black can go King
E6 so Bishop
A5 Knight
F5 Bishop
B6 rings a
bell this is the counterpart of of kck's
game versus BV where Bishop F6 was
played so there is a level of
synchronicity in this game too where of
course you can't touch this because I'm
just going to start promoting and this
Knight is just so far away and is denied
so many vital squares it can stop vishy
from winning and now the whole line of
defense just collapses for ponomarov
check
Rook C8 of course you still can touch it
because CB Rook takes check King
B4
takes King A3 Rook B6 making sure
they're enough Defenders and the King
May slide through just to avoid the KN
checks takes C6 and that pawn is rather
far away
C7 check King A3 and the King will run
away so he didn't even give this check
but at the end of the day the king would
just run through and the ca Pawn
promotes really well selected games
synchron city everywhere I agree so I
really hope all of you enjoyed these
games hope you learned a thing or two
how the goats prepare and actually come
up with a game plan and look at that
sometimes having a selection of games
before you play A variation might come
in handy thank you so
[Music]
much